POI body tracers they look so cool but
they also look so hard isn't there any
way to get into this pocket of the poy
world without having to spend hundreds
of hours practicing to get there as it
turns out I think there might be in fact
I think I can probably teach you a body
Tracer in only 30
minutes Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today I am going to try and
speedrun you through a basic body Tracer
that I think I can teach in only half an
hour but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys pyro Tera light
toys and Ultra poy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- bus friend of
the channel Becca Becken thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission so check this out
this is a vertical snake it is actually
one of the first body tracers that I
ever learned even though I didn't really
know that it was a body Tracer at the
time and despite the fact that it looks
pretty complicated I think that actually
can be broken up into some pretty
manageable parts and I think that with
five simple steps that I have outlined
in my head I will be able to help you
get this particular body Tracer now bear
in mind I have claimed some other
beginner tricks like tuck turns should
be considered body tracers in the past
but with this one I want to give you
something that absolutely everybody
around you is going to know actually
qualifies so it's going to be a little
bit more steep of a learning curve but
there's a way better payoff at the end
too and real quickly before we dive in
if you like videos on PO spinning and
flow Arts please make sure to subscribe
to the channel as well as ring the bell
so you catch every video that drop all
right so let's get started with step
one all right so first things first we
need to learn how to do a reverse or
outward butterfly this is as opposed to
the inward one that is more common but
it's the one that we want for this
particular body Tracer here's how we're
going to do it first up wrap up the poy
in your hands so that they're not
flopping about and I want you to perform
just that outward butterfly with your
arms I'm a big fan in training POI moves
by using your naturally occurring
awareness of your body in order to build
that same awareness for your POI and
this is a great exercise for doing it as
you're performing these outward
butterflies with your arms make sure
they're at full extension I want you to
give me 10 reps of this just to get a
feel for it after you got those 10 reps
down I want you to go ahead and let out
one coil the poy they should be no
longer than elbow length when you do so
and repeat the same exercise I want you
to perform that same outwards butterfly
with the p now poking out as a very very
short extension of your arms probably
you're going to have to adjust the speed
of your arms just a little bit until you
find an equilibrium where the POI are
not flopping nor are they flying around
all wildly you just want to keep a nice
slow pace as you're doing this cool so
once it gets to feel comfortable doing
10 reps of this that is with the POI at
half length I want you to go ahead and
let them out to full length and repeat
this same exercise I want you to perform
10 reps with your arms and POI at full
extensions this takes up a lot of room
so maybe practice it outside or
someplace where you got high ceilings
totally up to you but make sure to get
to a point where you can do 10 reps of
this fairly
comfortably all right so once this feels
comfortable we're going to start moving
down to only doing those big circles
from our elbows instead of from our
shoulders and it brings down the total
size of the circles but we still using
our arms to find our way there once you
can do 10 reps of this comfortably go
down to only performing these circles
from your wrists and guess what you now
have your outwards butterfly um you
might have an issue with the PO running
into each other either at the bottom or
the top of their Arc the way you fix
that is to realize that the PO plane
should be at a little bit of an angle
that is if you look at them from the
side one of them is going to be tilting
slightly back towards you and the other
one's going to be tilting slightly away
from you I generally find that whichever
hand is on bottom that winds up being
the plane that's tilted away but either
way you want to get to a point where you
can keep the pois spinning in that
outward butterfly for 10 reps when you
get there you're ready for step
two all right so once those outward
butterflies are feeling pretty
comfortable now it's time for us to get
to a point where we can perform reels at
our hips with those outward butterflies
this going to be a little bit of a
process but I think we can get there
first thing I want you to do is I want
you to point your index finger on your
right hand out to the right side and I
want you to kind of slice it down around
and poke it behind you for a second and
then come back out again point out slice
it around and then back out what you're
trying to do right here is get
comfortable performing a little circle
back behind your elbow and then bringing
your finger back out the reason being I
want you to practice doing this very
same thing with the POI we'll start out
by just doing what I would refer to as a
Tic Tac taking the PO back and forth
across your body like so and we're going
to move that over to the side of us so
we're looking at it from uh full profile
rather than from uh straight on and as
it stands right now the pois is always
staying on the top part of my hand like
my thumb is always pointed upward but I
want to do this in such a way that I
point my thumb down for a second as the
pois sweeps behind me like so one way
that you can think of this actually is
if you want to kind of start with the
poy spinning forwards on your side as
you face over to Stage right you can
turn a little bit and as you face to
stage left you flick that finger around
behind you and you turn so that the poy
is now spinning reverse over on your
stage left side so again spinning
forwards and as we turn boom We sweep it
behind us and then back out with that
little flip of the index finger and we
wind up with it spinning reverse over on
stage left we then have to learn how to
do the same thing with the left hand
spinning it forwards doing that flick
with the finger and then bringing it out
and around you want to make sure that as
you're doing this you're getting the PO
to spin once back behind your elbow with
your thumb pointed down and your wrist
pointing the palm of your hand behind
you that's the important part of this
equation here
and once you get that down with both
hands I want you to practice alternating
going back and forth with each of them I
want you to be able to keep one hand and
point in front of you and one behind you
at all times you're basically
alternating back and forth back and
fourth to get there you can start off
facing to Stage right and thinking 3 2 1
and turn over to stage left we think
three 2 one and turn
do 10 reps of that and then facing over
to Stage right thinking one two and turn
over to stage left we go one two and
turn back to Stage right one two and
turn back to stage left one two and turn
and now we want to do it on ones so we
want to think just one and turn one and
turn one and turn and one and turn again
you want to be get to 10 reps of this
before just taking out the rep entirely
thinking that we Face stage right stage
left stage right stage left stage right
stage left stage right stage left and at
this point you're going back and forth
performing those hip rails so you're in
a good place and you no longer have to
move your uh your face back and forth to
either side in order to get there
congratulations and that means you're
now ready for step three
so step three is going to look a lot
like step two the difference is that
we're learning how to do these reels
around our shoulders instead of around
our hips so just like we did with the
last one we're going to build up to it
start off by giving me those Tic Tacs
off to the side and specifically I want
you to reach your arm as far out away
from you as you possibly can as you're
performing those Tic Tacs back and forth
and then bend your elbow so that your
hand comes up next to your ear go back
and forth like this for 10 rep with your
right hand and then do the same thing
with your left hand extend your arm all
the way out going back and forth and
then bend the elbow keep your hand up
next to your ear and go back and forth
for 10 reps like so all right so now we
need to get it down so that the hands
are each working at the same time and
the best way I know how to do that is
build up to it just like we did with our
last exercise so here's how you're going
to get your right hand pois spinning
forwards on your right hand side and
your left hand pois spinning reverse on
your left hand side holding them up
close your ears as you face over to
Stage right you're going to do three 2
one beats and turn with them so that now
the right PO is going reverse and the
left PO is going forwards as you face
over to stage left and once again you're
going to think three 2 one and Turn 3 2
1 3 2 1 3 2 1 you want to get in 10 reps
at three counts on each side and then
you're going to think
one 2 one 2 one 2 one two again try and
get in 10 reps of this version of the
exercise and then finally you're just
going to go down to doing one one one
one as you go straight back and forth
and if it's easier at this point to just
move your hands back and forth rather
than move your shoulders that's totally
fine you can also keep your shoulders
moving either way I want you to be able
to get in 10 10 reps as you're switching
back and forth with your PO going in
front of and behind you always one in
front always one behind switching back
and forth like so and when you can get
10 reps of that in you're ready for step
four cool so for step four we're
actually going to combine together steps
two and three basically I'm going to
start off by performing 1 2 3 four reps
at my hips and then moving up to my
shoulders for another one 2 3 four reps
I come back down to my hips I want to
think one 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
be really really really careful with
your timing as you're doing this make
sure that you're keeping the PO in
together time so they're always coming
up at the same time we don't want to get
into uh split time here where you get
one on top and one on bottom we want to
make sure they're both on bottom and
then both on top together so again we
want to get in 10 reps of this we want
to think 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 again 1 2 3 4 1
2 3 4 like so going back and forth
between the bottom and the top and going
back down again and when you can get in
10 reps going back and forth between the
the bottom and the top you're ready for
our final step to put the whole thing
together all right so believe it or not
if you've done this exercise where
you're doing the multiple beats on top
and on bottom you already have all the
pieces you need to be able to do the
full trick we just need to reduce the
number of reps that you're doing on top
and on bottom so let's work on doing
that shall we start off by giving me one
two three on bottom one two three on top
one 2 3 one 2 3 one 2 3 1 2 3 get
comfortable just doing those three beats
and most important of all make sure
you're able to shift instantly back and
forth so if I've got my right going
behind me on my final count on the
bottom I'll have my left going behind me
on my first count going up top think
right left right and then left right
left like
once you can get 10 reps of that down
we're going to move down to only doing
two reps in each spot so we're going to
think one 2 one two one two one two like
so one two one two one two one two again
we want to shoot for 10 reps and when
that's comfortable we want to go down to
only doing one rep in each spot we going
to think one one one one one one one one
one like so and at that point you
actually do have the move down the only
thing you got to change about this is as
you're bringing the PO around down
spread out your arms like that extension
that we started with in our first
exercise and you're there think right
behind left behind out left behind right
behind out right behind left behind out
left behind right behind out again try
and keep your timing consistent right
left out left right out right left out
left right out and that's the move sweet
I hope this was helpful if you got the
move down please post video of it online
and make sure to tag me I would love to
come see your hard work and I will even
leave you a little bit of encouragement
there too and if you're hungry to learn
more about body tracing you're in luck
because that is the theme for this
month's flow Circle the flow circle is a
weekly exclusive lesson that's available
only to my patreon supporters and this
month we're focusing in on body tracers
everything from the basic skills of
using reels and linear isolations all
the way up to figuring out specific
moves like Archer weave fountains and
even a recipe by which you can turn Most
flowers into body tracers as well to
check that out go sign up over at
patreon.com drexfactor poy the first
lesson is available now did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it and of
course to help my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much you
all rock and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
signing up in my patreon over at
patreon.com / drexfactor po there you
can find a whole host of awesome rewards
but even better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you like the idea of
learning py Trix in only a half an hour
I will go ahead and link to a video I
did teaching POI flowers in only 30
minutes that I will link to down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourself today and I'll
will see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace